[Music]
before I started this program I thought
love was a feeling but that's [__]
it's a decision I did hack into my
supermarket's Instagram account and
posted a picture of my [__] and said
there was a sale on [__]
big deal of all the gin joints no way
Jade were you just in that meeting oh
yeah yeah sure was are you here pick up
women
no not women no just you evidently I
lost my virginity to was at my sex acts
meaning I went to a few meetings because
my therapist suggested that it might
help with the love addiction what's your
Excuse some suggested that I have a
little bit of a problem staying faithful
we gotta just be proud okay but then we
got to come up with the system we come
up with a safe word we're having sexual
tension in the picket chicken a
mousetrap
yikes what is that oh that's awful you
don't like it no what will you take
Molly with me and go to a kid's birthday
party I literally thought you'd never
ask
this takes time Laney who he really
wants to [__] yeah really wants to get
deep deep up in their gross what
positions did you do I made it
everything what's your favorite
Elizabeth will come behind exactly as
you hate your dad oh my god we think you
two are the coolest married couple ever
we don't get that no thank you
this varies heating up emotional real
estate that could be occupied by a real
option you wanna talk about it what
about what we're not a couple but we act
like one when you start sleeping with
people you risk losing them never slept
with someone I wasn't willing to lose
you haven't had an orgasm in a year
recreate that tray again is to be moved
to the first okay like hey you know you
know you like your scratch or record but
the job but let let let the drummer get
quick dude I'm gonna go home yeah we
don't yes I do
that's never gonna change
[Music]
hey good teacher but not touka Oh Canada
[Applause]